if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
dumps big massive
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps dumps
dumps dump big massive
[Music]
toilets 10 times 15 times as opposed to
once
all right everybody let me just cut in
um the news is
it's just too big i uh i i did flush 22
times actually just now uh not 10 or 15
as donald trump often suggests
and we are here standing by for the
verdict
in the george floyd murder trial
the world is watching the country is
watching and we
somewhere between 37 and 67 minutes from
now
we'll see not only what the verdict is
for former police officer derek chauvin
we will see
whether a deranged and delusional
closing statement
by his attorney eric nelson worked on
the jury
um and we will also see whether
the fears about unrest uh in in um
in various parts of the country
including minnesota uh
are warranted or not so thank you for
joining me it's been so long since i
i streamed and i'll explain a little bit
about why and i have so many different
things that i'm excited about
it's actually good that we have a little
bit of time before things get started
by the way i'm just noticing there are
massive dumps of support happening on
twitch uh so
odw is sending thousands of bits just
just
thousands and thousands of bits snuggles
and all sorts of people
i can't even deal with that right now
because what we have going on is so huge
um but as you can see it's been a while
since
i streamed we are all the way down to
732 subs on twitch i ended up being away
all of last week
i was helping helping my parents with
some stuff i had a bunch of different
elements of medical appointments let me
report to you what we have determined
dental from the standpoint of dental
no cavities no gum recession
my flossing is pretty good a couple
different tweaks that i've been advised
to make
but really really strong dental cleaning
so i think all of you will be very very
happy about that
and then i had my eye doctor appointment
i could tell that my contacts were just
a little bit off
and my eye doctor i've been going to for
a while
um he did a whole thing and then he at
the end of the exam he said sir
i've got you seeing 2015 with your
adjusted contacts properly
you know astigmatism and the entire
thing he said we've never seen anything
like this
uh and he even called the
ophthalmologist he's this is the
optometrist he said you've got to come
in here and see what i've been able to
do
they've given these tests to thousands
of people
he never saw anybody do what i did
yesterday
and so uh everybody will be and i'll
have my new updated prescription really
soon so i think that
i mean if that's not something to be
excited about i don't know what is
um okay what else
the thing that was not so good though is
they give you the dilation drops to see
in there and then they
used to have a reverse like an antidote
drop but i guess it raised eye pressure
i don't i didn't you know i know we're
getting into optometry my specialty my
specialty is in podiatry so i'm a little
bit outside of my
area but um i guess you would get an
elevated
eye pressure from the reversal drop so
they don't give you the antidote anymore
it was like five hours of me having to
wear sunglasses indoors
it was horrifying horrifying stuff okay
now that we've gotten the medical out of
the way where else to go
um oh i have a new caller to introduce
to you guys which we will get to in a
little bit
i have one unban request it seems to be
like
a joke unban request this is from the
user that many of you know
on uh twitch who goes by the name
fnug varangler and they've contributed
um emotes and different things i guess
they deliberately got themselves banned
in order for me to read the following
message
i said nothing when the cancel culture
came for dr seuss i felt like saying
something when the cancel
culture came from mr potato head but
said nothing now the cancel culture has
come for me
why that's respectable so i am going to
unban
phnugrongler unbanned decision
and new grongler has been unbanned
and they're back we want them here it
was i guess a joke
unban request i don't know okay let's
look at a few
of the super chats that are coming in hi
david from the uk what's going on with
the apparent mistrial
no mistrial declared there will be a
verdict although the maxine waters
comments may be
substance for a future appeal
uh david you rock thank you so the eye
doctor called ophthalmologist rand paul
yeah my optometrist was like sir i can't
believe what you're doing they called
ophthalmologist rand paul and said we're
both wearing masks but vaccinated what
do you think
rand was furious steven says i have a
stash of reversal drops do you want some
david
i'm i'm good now um my eyes are
totally fine uh perfect
at this point in time okay unban
requests
done whoa really strong super chat 100
super chat from joseph gundell or gundle
who says big fan
keep it up thanks joseph very much
appreciate that
here's what i have for you guys uh oh
wait a second hold on
oh okay do you want to do maybe the
dumbest dave rubin commentary ever or do
you want to do
new anti-semitic anti-trans collar
female voicemail caller this is the
first ever female
persistent voicemail troll that we've
ever had we've had many
i mean dozens of male persistent trolls
but what do you want first reuben we're
doing both oh everybody relax we're
doing both or the female
anti-trans anti-semitic troll
um very informal
very very informal reuben first okay
let's do reuben as we stand by here for
the
chauvin verdict uh here is i can't think
of a dumber commentary that i've ever
seen from dave rubin
and i've interviewed him where he said
things to me that are pretty dumb
let's take a listen to this let me talk
directly to you guys you ontario canada
legislators right you guys are evil nazi
[ __ ]
okay you understand what we just heard
there you should snitch on people
at the end police now will be empowered
to just pull you over and ask whatever
they want if they see someone not at
home
they can basically ask for your papers
and what you're doing out on the street
how do you think evil spreads this is
how evil spreads
these are bad brainwashed people
and there is a disease of the mind
spreading across the west and canada
boy are you guys jealous of our second
amendment now because
it would at least have more pushback if
that was coming in the united states but
i suspect
canadians who in many cases are are just
kind of nice and stay out of people's
lives
what on earth is this that they're
folding quicker i think they're just
folding quicker
than say americans would not all
canadians there are plenty of canadians
you guys understand what the commentary
is here like what is the commentary
actually what is he talking about
gideon's fighting it you know that
jordan peterson guy up there
and my buddy gad sad and viva frey
there's a bunch of other people
viva frey what is that ezreal event
over at the rebel there's a bunch of
people fighting that but those are
horrific bone chilling statements that
those people
are saying what they are going to do
with law enforcement oh there's covet
guidelines in ontario that's what this
is about it's like nazism
oh my god that's giga cringe guys and
make sure
you are trapped in your house okay all
right so there's dave rubin
um ontario premier said some dumb crap
during covet lockdown oh okay
a defiant and principled rant by dave
rubin
we have surpassed joseph's hundred
dollar super chat
danny thompson with a 125 bomb
being here in hennepin county the mood
is very tense buildings even on the
south side of the county are boarded up
in anticipation of the verdict
still 30 to 60 minutes before the
verdict to be read nice to catch you on
a live stream again
whoa something happening here uh
it maybe it maybe now actually it may
not be true that it's 30 to 60 minutes
they just held up something there um
thanks for all your great work thank you
danny
day 28 minnesota versus chavan day 16 of
trial
okay we are standing by it looks like
the judge is back we may actually see
this soon
i do want to say thank you to jalen
alexander jalen just did
basically the most beautiful thing you
could do jalen grabbed a membership on
my website joinedpakman.com
using that code better21 thank you
jalen also thank you to sean mcgillin
that is two new members if we get to a
hundred i'll do some phone lines it's
been a while since we've opened phone
lines
uh let's also see what's happening on
twitch i wanna say thanks to polo dal
fidel trump the weebs
neptune northwestern giraffe
matrobe that's six twisted hawk is seven
chris houlihan is eight tyrannos
is nine combo carl is 10
tecolote 11 stoned knoll
12 canned caviar is number 13. give me
your milk please is number 14
small fuzz moss 15 skeptizy
16 adam vittle
17 k shreds 18 cosmos 19 crazy guy in
t20
um jalen cool 21
nod to nothing gifting 2 is 23 plus 2 is
25.
uh so we're we're well on our way here
um okay other super chats
david do you not have any mods for the
youtube chat pre pretty awful comments
coming in we should
we should have mods there guy with the
hair asks if i've seen the mic pillow
prank call from trump impersonator i did
see it
i did see it it honestly i didn't find
it that funny i don't know why
um geron also asking did i see mike
pillow pranked on live tv during his
launch event
yeah it was it was funny it just i don't
know why it didn't strike me as like the
funniest thing
but uh compelling stuff sometimes you
have to see
whoa a lot happening here let's see uh
all right we're keeping an eye on the
derrick chauvin verdict everybody relax
we are not going to miss it
um if you want to see something wild
here is eric nelson yesterday comparing
the trial
to elements of baking a chocolate chip
cookie
take a listen a criminal case is kind of
like baking chocolate chip cookies
right you have to have the necessary
ingredients you've got to have
flour and sugar and butter and chocolate
chips
whatever else goes into those chocolate
chip cookies now this
does sound idiotic but this eric nelson
may have correctly taken the pulse
of the jury where he may be correctly
calculating that this will work
i i mean it's it's delusional but i'm
not saying it's a bad strategy
he knows the jury i we don't know
anything about the job you know a little
but
not much about the jury if you have
all of the ingredients you can make
chocolate chip cookies
but if you're missing any one single
ingredient
you can't make chocolate chip cookies
it's not even really true like as i said
on the broadcast show today
you might be missing eggs but you can
use applesauce you might be missing
butter but you can use
canola oil you might be missing
chocolate chips but you can put in
nougat chips
you know i mean it's like it's a stupid
analogy but
he may know what he's doing we will see
moments from now
it's a simple kind of analogy but the
criminal
law works the same way we say
the ingredient we call the ingredients
the elements elements the state has the
burden of proving
each and every element beyond a
reasonable doubt
those are elements of legal
so to speak um let's see what else i
mean i went we have a whole clip on this
so i don't want to redo all of it
um here is where he says listen derek
chovin should get credit because he
didn't punch kick her elbow
george floyd officer chauvin made a
decision
not to use higher levels of force right
he would have been authorized to do that
including punches kicks elbows right
he deserves credit guys he didn't kill
and elbow george floyd
he only killed him could have elbowed
him
could have done all sorts of it could
have spit on him you know he didn't spit
he just killed him he didn't kill kill
and spit on him so uh and by yeah
what is a higher level of force than
killing very strange closing statement
but again
he knows the jury better than we do and
we will see
very soon very soon whether that uh
ends up working i want to say thank you
to daniel
juryevs for subscribing on my website i
also want to say thanks to benjamin
melville for the new subscription on my
website
and also thank you to scott taggart who
are new members number 26 27 and 28
today
also thank you to stony dub chill sd
palo santo [ __ ] the wilhelm screen
jonah landry for the twitch subs putting
us at 33. we will open phone lines
after the verdict if we get to 100.
um okay let's do
david applesauce instead of eggs am i
missing something does it work yeah it's
just an emulsifier that does work i i
don't do it
i know that a lot of people who are
looking for vegan recipes will replace
eggs with applesauce in various baked
goods
and that it will um function as a
working emulsifier
and binder not emulsifier binder may be
better said
um i haven't waited for a jury verdict
like this since the o.j simpson trial
yeah you know when the o.j simpson trial
happened i was in school
and there was a code that the teachers
agreed there would be an announcement
made when the verdict happened and the
code for not guilty was the butterfly
flies free and i remember it i remember
it like it was yesterday
uh it was actually last week but i
remember like it was yesterday there was
like a
bing the butterfly flies free and that
was code to the teachers
who were awaiting the oj verdict that it
was an acquittal
an acquittal oh phone calls okay yeah
very good
let's get to the phone calls we have a
new caller
let me just put in the number here this
is a
um this is a female caller
okay um
well what was that
looks like sound from the courthouse is
coming in and out all right i'm just
gonna play these voicemails take a
listen to this
since your party is run by
a man that has brain damage doesn't it
kind of give you the clue
that some of your morals might be
questionable
like taking children and changing their
gender
so that's on trans let's listen to the
next one
we need a nickname for this caller yeah
of course
like look at the republican party look
how intelligent bill is
and bill thinks that giving everybody
drugs
would be better than switching people's
genders
who's a bill who's she talking about
it's violence and i just i don't agree
with it
and i just think that like if you're
gonna do something that risky
there better be somebody really
intelligent backing them up
because i was like i don't see you
talking about how it's cool to
take his little kid and change his or
her gender even though it's like who is
that
how can you tell that that's like a man
or a girl at that age
it's ridiculous a man or a girl it's
like
kk karen that's not bad i like that
that's nicely done bobo fetra
kk karen maybe works obviously
not run by some scientific method that
like
intelligent people are agreeing on
because i don't see any intelligent
people
that are talking about how like this is
right that this is like you know what
god wanted or
you know what not okay uh and it
continued this is a doozy i don't know
if we'll get
through this one
so um i was thinking about some of the
main reasons
why transsexuals aren't getting a lot of
respect
dear god and one of the reasons why i
thought that you know one of the reasons
that's kind of understandable
is that they would sleep so low as to
making children transgenders so
i mean based off of that that they would
be willing to
make somebody maybe accidentally the
wrong
gender in order to
up themselves in society brain damage
brittany's not bad yeah
jkk rowling that's pretty good
i think the best one so far i'm going to
write them down
kk karen j kkk
rowling um
and brain damage brittany
that's not bad we'll workshop those
being to get themselves right
because they were born wrong i don't
feel like that's fair
i think that people who were born right
should be um top priority
if you're you know you know if you were
born if you think you're born you know
what's interesting is i actually am not
hearing anything anti-semitic right now
i had a note that it was transphobic and
anti-semitic
i'm not actually hearing anything and
she probably is anti-semitic but
it's not i'm not hearing that um
if you think you were supposed to be a
boy but you were born a girl like i
don't think that should be a priority
over somebody who was born a boy
and who is a boy and i just think that
it's really difficult to respect
somebody who would do that to a child
and
the amount of science i feel like is
necessary to go into something like that
like the average person isn't going to
have the time
or the trust with their government what
hold on is something happening nope just
background noise
i'll mute for now just i'll keep an eye
on it
in order to actually make like a right
assessment with that
so i just think okay hal doll
hayley is not bad either but i don't
want to stigmatize mental illness
because there's
you know but for people who are
prescribed i mean it's not a you know i
i don't i don't want to stigmatize so
that's why i'm not going to go with that
better to you know be like some people
don't have good luck with their lives
like
some people are poor when they want to
be rich
it doesn't mean that we should give them
lots of money
just because they were born poor and all
right so there's 30 more seconds of that
than she called just two hours ago and
left me another one let's
this is the last one
so growing up people treated me like i
was a boy
and i have oh well now this takes on
this is now
maybe there is a resentment here that
there are people who now are living as
they
uh want to oh now it takes a different
turn
hold on a second let's continue certain
reactions to people treating me
like a boy and the thing is
i grew up and i moved out of vermont and
i realized that
you know that's like the attitude there
is that you can
act like a boy and fit in because it's
just
normal there and when i moved
i felt more like a girl i came out to
california i've
you know learned how to dress and do my
hair and all this other kinds of stuff
and
i'm definitely a woman and the thing is
is that i can think in terms of what i
would do
if i was a boy hmm a lot you know
my initial reaction to something like
this is
why why are you calling me every couple
hours about trans
you know and now it's sort of like oh
now maybe this is why she's obsessed
maybe she's obsessed because this this
is projection
which is sad actually i mean i don't
that's not that's not something to make
fun of
what i would do as a woman if somebody
made me a boy
should not be the same things that men
do
because you were born men were born
yeah this i'm gonna bail because it's
now taken on more of a sad element
it's just it's just sad now it seems
like this is someone who maybe
is trans but has decided that
because they were not able to
sort of live their life as they wanted
to they now are taking it out on
everybody else and saying everybody else
is
mentally ill and crazy and all this
different stuff
okay so anyway that's a new caller kind
of bummed out now
but we'll move on yeah it's a little
heavy it's a little heavy
um she's treating me like a confession
booth exactly exactly danny thompson
coming in with a really
really powerful 50 super chat i'm
watching local news here anxiety off the
chart for the verdict
locally we thought chauvin's lawyer was
taking wild swings and not all that
effective
county buildings and libraries closed
for safety
other minneapolis businesses closing
early as well
yeah we're standing by we don't know uh
we don't we just don't know what the
verdict is going to be
producer pat earlier told me that faster
is considered better for the prosecution
but has
is it fast they started deliberating
yesterday and we heard there's a verdict
45 minutes ago i don't know if that's
considered fast even
let me thank some awesome people i want
to say thank you to stephanie green who
just signed up at joinpakman.com
i want to say thank you to susan
sappington who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and i want to say thank you to anthony
kirket
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
using the coupon code better21 they are
new members 34 35 and 36.
now i do there's a lot of people that
are maybe not familiar with
with our channel or anything that is the
published coupon code there better 21.
there's a secret unpublished code which
is immoral 21
and that's just because the koopa it's
such an extreme coupon code that the
morality is in question
and so if you want you can use that
unpublished code
on my website all right also want to get
caught up over on twitch milo wilde has
just gifted five subs
paddy don't surf signed up is number six
pedia griffin
is number seven laura murray is number
eight andy of the dead number nine
astro lycos 10. hey it's larissa 11.
beanchore boy
number 12 hurricane ella number 13
r grilinski is 14 red team go number 15
stoney dub 16 chill sd17
i think that's everybody 17 puts us at
53.
uh okay there we go if you're just
joining everybody relax
you've you've missed nothing you've
missed nothing we are standing by the
verdict expected
as soon as 13 minutes from now
up to 43 sometime between the bottom of
the hour and the top of the next hour
um oh since i have a minute let me
mention something else
so i get like four to five emails a week
from people who say uh sir we've started
a new
uh platform social media platform video
platform whatever
uh we would like you to put your content
on it we want you to post on it
we do this we do that whatever and 99.9
percent of the times it's it's garbage
it's just pond scum and it's not worth
my time
uh i actually spent the weekend on a new
platform
that i'm really excited about and what's
what i love about this platform is that
there's serious
people behind it um but it's still so
small
that my audience is theoretically big
enough that we could take over this
platform right now
and we could push pacman coin to the top
okay the platform is called bitclout
bitclout you can find it at
davidpakman.combitcloud
the top people that are actually on it
are the people with these blue check
marks
so it's uh craig clemons the viral
sensation
chamath polypedia you know like a few
other people
but we could actually like 6 000
followers puts you at the top of this
platform
so we're gonna be launching a bunch of
new stuff on here we haven't launched
launched on any new platform i think for
months
um so follow me on here just learn about
it that's all
it costs nothing like there's a token
and it's like crypto based and all this
different stuff
who cares just follow me on it because
what i've been told is
if we can get a jump start on this
platform which is expected to explode
very very soon
um it could be like nobody's ever heard
of it will be more
shocking than my optometry report uh so
that's davidpakman.combitclout
and i will be um i'm already posting on
there i'm actually going to be doing a
couple interviews with some of the big
people on the platform very soon and
very strongly
so that's a new thing i spent the
weekend on that
um what else did i have the j oh the
reuben thing we already did
so i don't have to do that um
oh yeah right so am i offering anything
special on big cloud yeah
so for the top holders i am going to be
offering a direct message thing where
you can actually just direct message me
and i will reply like i get 100 dms a
day on instagram i can't keep up with it
my top 20 holders will be able to direct
message me and i will actually reply
that's it that's the whole that's the
whole pitch there's no other pitch
happening
happening uh all right very good so
we've got
that um what else is going on
oh let me look at a few other super
chats big cloud is a confirmed scam vids
on it yeah i've researched it i don't
see that at all
i think it's super interesting actually
uh if i'm wrong i will i will
uh i i you know i'll mention it
but i spent the weekend researching good
to see you have over 1.32 million
subscribers now what do you think the
verdict will be i have no idea
i have no idea what's your take on the
maxine waters controversy i think it was
a very bad idea for her to say if it is
an acquittal
then people need to get more
confrontational i just think i have no
you know people have been writing to me
saying david oh you're not in
you're not listening you're not
commenting on maxine i'm commenting
right now i think it was a huge mistake
for her to say what she did
it is a huge mistake to say the
protesters should become more
confrontational if there's an acquittal
it doesn't even matter whether the jury
was sequestered or not at the time they
were not
they were not uh terrible terrible
terrible uh idea
equally important in the uk we all need
this verdict
um okay so we are we are standing by for
the verdict yes
no question about that few other thank
yous i want to say thanks to candy's pop
in as well as thurs daddy the real jesus
christ snezzly wipes
cincatash that's four milo wild gifting
five subs
very oh no i already thanked milo wild
so that's 57 having trouble keeping up
with some of these numbers
um oh whoa hold on a second
we just got a big membership dump aubrey
trout
aubry trout new member on my website
sepe sheridan has signed up
brooks grant new member michael truman
new member number four
jonathan poulter number five phil
wilutz number six
thanks to etienne buteau number seven
marcus sakes is new member number eight
nuk fig number nine
brandt moore is new member number ten
james sorelle
number eleven isabel wright is new
member number 12 on my website
and caleb king number 13 putting us at
70. and as i mentioned i will take some
phone calls if we get to a hundred
after the verdict the verdict could be
just minutes away
could be eight minutes away could be a
half hour
could be a half hour um
any upcoming coverage of the virginia
gubernatorial election
nothing confirmed right now nothing
confirmed but
i'm up for covering uh whatever people
are interested in let me make a note
about that
so i don't forget to look into that
chef's pawn says thank you for covering
this my pleasure
my pleasure um
important important and obviously we we
hope uh
we hope for safety and peace and calm
after the fact
okay you missed a few super chats david
can you do a video on the anti-semitic
murder of sarah halimi recently the
criminal behind her murder just free
there's no justice now
i'm not familiar with that i will look
into it
i will look into that people who are
just joining you have not missed the
verdict we are standing by
for the verdict nothing has happened yet
uh let's take a listen to what's
happening here i'm just saying that when
you're faced with mounds and mounds of
testimony
and weeks of your notes and weeks of 11
other jurors notes
to be able to have something in front of
you that's a chart
that you can check off that's organized
by someone else that actually
coordinates with judges instructions
i i have found before is a very helpful
tool
for people if you just think of it in
terms of human nature in terms of
processing information in terms of
processing emotional information so for
example i'm holding here in my hand this
is the complaint against derek chovin
it it's it's not very long but it's just
a lot of words written in prose right as
opposed to
the prosecution's chart that just had
here's the first element here's the
second element here's the third element
and here's what you need to prove
okay so we're standing by for the
verdict coming momentarily
possibly as soon as six minutes from now
possibly a little longer
what's your take on the frank speech
launch i
i looked it up yesterday there was a 502
bad gateway error
and then i gave up that was it do you
have an opinion on how european
and world politics is going to change
well when angela merkel leaves office
after 16 years as german
chancellor i think it'll uh there will
be a sort of vacuum
particularly remember that when donald
trump was elected
colloquially speaking angela merkel was
widely considered to have become the
leader of the free world
sort of the adult in the room
and so i think there will be a question
as to whether germany
is diminished in some sense in terms of
global
stature i think we just don't know yet
but an interesting question
does anyone else want to see derek
chauvin cry like the cowardly little man
he is oh that's that's not good that's
not good
cbd shop sells delta eight was great to
walk in and buy openly today have a
wonderful day
okay don't i don't even understand that
how many times have you been mistaken
for american and is it beneficial
it's rarely beneficial it's rarely
beneficial
no uh but i mean i i basically am
american i was five when i moved to the
u.s
great channel david valuable stuff thank
you
alex says happy 420. a lot of people
very very excited
want to say thanks to clax johnson as
well as too damn lucky
um monger poutine
as well as its future man
loki lon twitch that's five
seventy plus five is seventy five
also want to say a big thank you to
uh molina peters aaron benitez
sven egley jennifer hayner
kyle harvey and laurie miller all of
whom just took advantage of some
pretty pretty vile actually coupon codes
on my website
uh we are standing by for the derek
chauvin verdict you have not missed it
you have not missed it you have not
missed it yes i'm a citizen and i vote
in the united states let's see here
my sister is an nypd officer she thinks
chauvin isn't getting any punishment i
hope she's wrong
we're so close that what's the point now
of speculating
we will know very soon
very very soon possible conviction on
manslaughter no confidence and other
charges either way lots of evidence for
defense to appeal
why should crimea return to crimea if
most crimeans want to be a part of
russia
i don't know that to be the case
but but i would investigate it gohmert
said if you don't get justice through
the court you have to be violent versus
maxine be confrontational get real david
whoa
mike with a shot across the bow
told my bro you were streaming says z
fisher the response was good better than
having to watch
wolf blitzer's bs oh my goodness one of
three brothers here and we love the show
thank you
does the dream act have a chance in the
senate i want to be optimistic
chris but it doesn't feel super strong
e.j slemp got called to jury duty
it requires bitcoin to follow you on
bitclout
i don't know how that doesn't sound
right i'm following a bunch of people
and i've done nothing on there
i've done no bit no elements of bitcoin
return to ukraine now septic avenger
says
okay yeah we're getting sort of off
there in terms of why
why we are here today um
but a lot of people actually concerned
with the ukraine russia situation
there's some revolutionary leftists who
are getting pretty aggressive on that
issue as well i don't really watch their
shows
but some of the news summaries i get
have pointed it out
and um some people are kind of off the
deep end i
venture to say love the the show
genes keep them high and tight
thanks jay i think does a verdict mean
it isn't a hung jury
yes yes if it were a hung jury they
would not say
a verdict has been reached there would
be you know a situation where they say
the jury is unable to reach a verdict
the the as far as the report now
uh is that a verdict has been reached
and we are going to hear it
somewhere between 1 and 31 minutes from
now
so it will be impactful
and um i'm being told jurors are in the
room
okay oh looks like we have some live
audio yeah
okay let's see here toady capote has
subbed on twitch as well as flurries
colors atk as well and uh trish the dish
as well as hack phooey putting us at 86.
i will
i see people asking about phones we will
do phones we will do phones if we get to
a hundred and and we're headed in that
direction so we may very well do that
are there people of color on the jury
yes
yes there are at least biracial people
on the jury and
people in the chat can correct me if i'm
wrong
um it is not a hung jury as far as we
know it is a
it is a verdict and we are expecting it
very soon very very soon
uh do i think there will be violence i i
don't know
i don't know i hope not um and my my
thought was that after the jury whatever
it is after the jury verdict
we will um
we will figure out what stream may
be carrying the aftermath let me see who
is going to cover that
maybe nbc we'll just have some backup
streams i i'm as curious as others
whatever the verdict is i'm curious
racial tensions between
okay so we're going to follow that let's
make sure we've got
strong hd video at least as strong as we
can
um yeah i'm hoping for a peaceful
peaceful situation
if civil occurs i'm guessing you mean if
civil unrest occurs
what is your opinion of the argument
that maxine water statement we've got to
get more confrontational could be
considered inciting a riot
i don't just curious on your take i
don't think i don't think it's inciting
a riot but i think that her comments
were just a bad idea
and other those people saying trump said
much worse yeah okay trump's an idiot
trump's horrifying um that's not a
reason to defend
i just think it was a bad idea who does
anyone think it's a what's the argument
that it's a good idea for in the last
days of a trial for maxine waters to say
what she did
like convince me that it's a good idea
guilty or not the day will not end well
says pepe xanadu
um savior jake wants a moment of silence
right now
moment of silence is a little odd on a
stream
we we remember what happened in
columbine but
i've never done a moment of silence on
the stream and i'm not i'm just not sure
about that right now
um just seems seems kind of strange
uh okay someone says did i know i was at
1.32 million subscribers i didn't but i
know now
now i know thank you for letting me know
a moment of acknowledgement yes we
acknowledge
uh let's see anniversary of columbine i
don't even i'm not sure of the date off
hand
um it's today okay
we acknowledge the anniversary
of the columbine shooting horrifying
horrifying
in a sense that shooting is
in my mind sort of the start of like the
modern mass shooting era is it wrong to
remember it that way
i know there were mass shootings before
that of course but it's sort of like a
uh
it's not oh i'm wrong okay all right
oh i'm right people are disagreeing
okay when the verdict is read says peter
one side or the other will suffer
consequences i highly doubt a hung jury
will satisfy these minnesotans
yeah you don't have to talk about a hung
jury because as far as we know there's a
verdict
oliver says i wonder what shenanigans
faux news is reporting on right now
instead of nationally relevant news i'm
sure
i would bet money that fox is carrying
the verdict
has anyone considered he may be found
guilty of all charges except for murder
that's a question for those in the uh
for those in the audience
uh the requisite comments that my coupon
code isn't working
uh it's working fine a whole bunch of
people have already signed up
there's two coupon codes better 21
that's the published coupon code
then there's the secret coupon code
immoral 21
both are working perfectly okay
cromag says i know this isn't your usual
thing but could you do a segment on
fetterman for pennsylvania senate
i'm a fan but curious on your feelings
about him i'll do you one better we're
trying to get him on the show and
actually interview him
i don't think he's responded but we are
trying to get uh
john fetterman on the program
should biden do something if it's not
guilty no come on guys
i'm not an authoritarian so that is not
that i would never say something like
that that's
that's not the way the system works
um i want to say thanks to do you grok
as well as short
brief bobofetra and
jimmy for signing up via twitch
bobofetra actually had a message hey
david can you say hi to my friend
jeffrey we worked together i introduced
him to your live streams thanks for all
you do yes of course hi jeffrey
great to have you here um
will i take phone calls after i probably
will
we have a goal of a hundred website
members and twitch subs were at 90.
so if that's the case i will it's always
via discord
we have gotten rid i actually got a um i
got a message from jimmy from philly the
other day
in fact i should i should look at
whether i have voicemails from jimmy
from philly
emailed me and said it's um
i'm getting a busy signal and i said
well you're calling the wrong number
jimmy
let me see here oh thanks to odw for
gifting 10 subs that puts us at 100 so
the phone lines will indeed open
okay let me see if i have any jimmy from
philly stuff because he asked for the
voicemail number
hold on i've got them let's see who this
is hi david i just need
you to understand that you have framed
this trump problem in an entirely is
this jimmy from philly i can't even tell
let me see here no this is a northern
california area
what you need to understand is that we
as a society as a whole
have basically confirmed donald trump's
assertion
that you could stand in the middle of
the street
and shoot somebody this guy keeps
calling back but i guess it's not jimmy
and my various assertions to that to the
very
facts at which i'm pointing are the
reasons that
my account has been locked okay yeah
we're gonna get away from that so
anyway i guess i don't he asked for the
number jimmy did
but then i guess he never called in um
i do have one from the eggman though
which you may find interesting
hey dave um regarding like the current
gun violence in our country for the past
forever yeah um i feel that expanded
background checks that we're all talking
about it's just it's not going to help
at all
i think that enforcing the current laws
that we do have right now
is not going to help at all and i think
that creating red flag laws
and enforcing the red flag laws in
conjunction
with the enforced or enhanced that sorry
background checks
is not going to help at all none of this
is going to help
dave the only way to get rid of the gun
violence is to make guns illegal
we have to take the guns if people want
guns
whoa that's aggressive to be registered
inspected and insured
inspected every year just like a car to
make sure it wasn't altered
um there's really no other way so i'm
asking you
is all this talk about expanded
background checks and
and voting on stuff is that all
political theater the thing is
so even if his ideas are good it'll
never happen i mean it's just a losing i
mean it's just
never going to happen so i don't know
why we there are things we could get
done i don't know why we would go to
things that are never going to happen
here's actually the eggman on shoving
let's listen to this
hey dave i just want to say that when
the defense for
our show derrick chauvin said that
george floyd could have been sleeping or
sun tanning or getting massage when he's
laying down
on the stomach at that point i knew they
lost i knew it i knew it
i'll tell you right now okay he's not
going to get 40 years he's not going to
get 20 but he'll get 12
years okay that's my i'm betting 12
years he's going to get there'll still
be angry writing people
and i would never eat a chocolate chip
cookie that you made
do not put applesauce or some other
emulsifiers that's disgusting
i'd rather eat a cookie from this racist
horrible defense lawyer
shalom brother all right so there's the
eggman weighing in really strongly on
some of these cookie elements
and not pleased okay so that's that
that's uh we've gone through all my
various voicemails
uh thank you very much um okay david
something may have changed with bitcloud
in the last couple days see my last
super chat okay i will look into that
guys everybody everybody relax
um i'm staying with your stream david
but status quo is live from outside the
court they are indie investigative
journals yes
uh status coup i once wrongly
said was a trump channel it's not a
trump channel
and let's see what they are doing that
non-trump channel status coup
is live let's see what they've got going
on
just very very strongly here okay
okay good this is good so status quo
doing a good job they are down on the
ground and we will get a sense
of the situation there as soon as soon
as soon as the jury verdict is read
um okay
all right good so we've got that and we
we should be no more than 20 minutes
from the verdict at this point in time
should be no more than 20 minutes
lavender says thanks for everything wish
i could give more
jb says i just had to support with what
i have you're a nice person and you put
things into perspective thank you
trump was president last time the phone
lines came on where they're coming on
today my friend
they're coming on today look at these
numbers devil can't cry has just gifted
two subs
devops bar has just sub tiny aim
ferdsteiger greater candle
that's like 106 i think and then look at
what's happening on the website right
now
i've never seen anything like this
valerie hebraiken
just signed up on my website ryan whedon
signed up judy dean thanks judy
jonathan taylor has just signed up gage
leonard
is a new member aaron brooks has signed
up
don hunt is a new member cliff cooper
has just signed up
chris gentry has just signed up putting
us at 113
i hope i'm pronouncing most of these
names correctly
some i do struggle with but i'm doing
the best i can
hey david you were my conversion to the
left
no matter the verdict everyone stay safe
how much would we have to pay you to
read fox in
socks by dr swess while impersonating
john lithgow oh i don't even know that
there's an amount for that
happy 429
greg smith is the worst status queue has
the best on the ground reporting of the
protest support them thanks to david for
the stream
should justice democrats vote as a block
and make progressive demands like
manchin does
who are the justice democrats right now
like who is in
i guess the house right are there's no
there's no justice democrat senators i
believe who is in the house like how big
is that block
i know very little about it
does anybody know
nobody knows oh boy
12 there's 12 justice democrats
hmm all right
david beautiful bathers checking in did
you ever fill the position as pat
understudy my brother so we're entering
the um interview
phase we had this new position we
announced we had about 350 people
initially apply
once the position description was
provided after an initial
sort of a triage where uh we you know
non-us workers were eliminated and there
were some others that weren't good fits
350.
i think we sent the job description to
about 300.
after that only about 250 said they want
to go forward
we sent a skills test to those 250
that dropped it to about oh
maybe a hundred or 125
and then on the basis of the skill tests
we were able to eliminate
actually most people and now we are in
the
interview phase which starts this week
and we're down to
you know a smaller number
um so we will it's a it's a process
it's a process thanks for your hard work
david enjoying the show
says dutch mcfaden they need to hurry up
i have a meeting at 2 p.m pacific
miss liv says thanks for being a voice
of reason big fan
what's your opinion on a health care
system like the one in denmark
i've studied the different european
health care systems although i don't
remember exactly how
denmark's works i'm more familiar with
the french system and the german system
so i need a refresher on how it works
i live in minneapolis the suspense of
this verdict is driving me crazy
if chauvin didn't kill george floyd my
brother imes would probably still be
alive
well i don't know that sounds bad i
don't know the details of that but i'm
sorry to hear that
there will be riots if it's not guilty
says the lost legacy
michael says doctoral candidate in human
conditioning and fear pathology sadly on
both sides people aren't looking for
justice they are looking for permission
have you thought about selling a david
pakman hat
not really no i haven't thought about
that that's not something i've looked at
in any any real detail if you're just
joining us
we are standing by oh hold on a second i
gotta ban someone sorry
and bam hammer there we go
sorry for the interruption um we are
standing by for the derek chauvin
verdict
status coup is live on the ground let's
listen
so fingers crossed praying
that um justice is served
thank you very much
there are there's a lot of press here
i'm live on the radio okay so keeping an
eye on the situation outside the
courthouse and then this is in how
inside the courthouse
um oh the squeaky gavel i still have the
gavel
it's just kind of um we had a technical
issue today
and it led to the gavel sort of being
tossed far from my desk
i don't need it because i don't have any
unban requests to adjudicate
oh oh no i do hold on a second oh let me
see if i can grab it hold on
oh here it is okay so on twitch
you can request an unban if you've been
banned
and uh then i will adjudicate it okay so
let's do that right now
here is a user named upstairshumor who
said um david's entire audience is
filled with disgusting shills who would
kill themselves if bernie told them to
do so
that's pretty bad they were banned
they've now requested an
unban saying the heat of the 20 that was
in january
they've now said the heat of the 2020
election got the better of me and i made
some stupid comments apologies to david
and the moderator team for that
you know what i'm going to give them the
benefit of the doubt that that's a good
faith
change they came back today three months
after they were banned to say that
i want to believe the best in people so
i am going to adjudicate that
unbanned let's give them a chance
let's give them a chance moderators keep
a very close eye
very very close eye next unban request
is from a user
who came in and said david pakman
misspelled
in triple parentheses which is a um
anti-semitic dog whistle or dog whistle
and then their unbanned request is lull
so it's true
it's true that i'm jewish it's
true that it's funny that i'm jewish
that is going to be
denied oh that was weird it didn't it
like didn't it glitched hold on it's
this side
there it is that is denied and made
permanent that is a perma-ban
um that concludes
the unbanned requests for today
uh okay yeah that was weird
it didn't squeak i think what happened
is the air
comes out right here and i think i might
have just
so perfectly done it that it just
blocked
the air that was strange all right so
that's
unban requests for the time being
um you just signed up on my website and
i didn't thank you okay i'm sorry let me
let me thank people right now
i want to say thanks to cameron
underhill for the
join pacman.com subscription adam ells
for signing up christian scardina has
signed up
colin shimf is a new member and kathy
snow
thanks kathy i appreciate that that puts
us at 118.
i also want to say thanks on twitch to
the hoosier daddy this is slammin
screwed scamender spit happens
as well as tangela irene deb kintai
um that's four
putting us at 122.
everybody relax we we haven't missed the
verdict we're waiting for the verdict
it's scheduled for right now
should be within the next 12 minutes
have i thought of wrestling sam cedar in
a cage match
i would do um australian rules boxing
and john wayne parr would coach me i
don't know how many of you guys are
familiar with john wayne parr
the uh i guess he's a kickboxer but he
he's a big fan of the show and i would
get him to coach me
and then i would get celebrity chef
tyler florence to just
design my uh my diet for training
that would be my team it would it would
be tyler florence
and then uh and then john wayne parr
would train me it's nice to know even if
convicted shogun
will be able to get a job with the
police sarcasm
david is that the band hammer from
chapulin colorado yes it is
exactly exactly david have you been
keeping up with the hikaru feingold
chess drama no no what's going on um
what's going on with uh hikaru and ben i
know that ben was doing some kind of
sub-battle with hikaru
can anybody catch me up on it
i i don't know what's going i thought
they were getting along to some degree i
don't know maybe somebody can let me
know
who's mad at what like my guess is ben
doesn't like the drama
the chess drama was between chess bra
and hikaru
yeah someone's gonna have to let me know
off off uh off stream
hikaru doesn't care feingold compared
nakamura to trump
yeah i don't know i'm gonna get away
from that because i don't think most of
my audience cares about it
i do care i'm like in that world a
little bit
but i think my audience doesn't care
sorry guys
who's physically stronger you or pat pat
is like twice my size
so on a pound-for-pound basis it could
be a fight
but in a raw muscle it's clearly pat's
like a foot taller than me
that's not there's it couldn't possibly
be close
i'm so sad this happened in minneapolis
because it's one of my favorite cities
with wonderful people have you been
i have i've been to minneapolis once and
it was for the netroots nation
progressive media conference
beautiful city have i cared for martial
arts as a hobby
no i didn't when i was a kid i when i
was seven
i did karate i believe it was
shorin ryu or something like that
um and i got like the little green
tip it was like a two inch tip they
stuck to the end of my belt
and then we went to argentina to visit
family and i just never went back
that's my uh that's it that's it
would i go on stephen crowder's show for
a debate i would but like
is it comedy or is it serious because
when i was on joe rogan's show
rogan told me crowder is a comedian so
i don't know we'd have to we'd have to
clear that up
david any updates on the mayoral race
nina turner is running in i thought she
was running for congress
nina turner is running for mayor i
thought i could have sworn she was
running for congress
does anybody know it is congress yeah i
don't know what your
this mayoral thing is yeah i don't know
about that
it's congress okay found out my brother
listens to your show that made me very
happy we both appreciate your ability
for nuance discussion
two million subs this year i don't think
so
i don't think there's any way we are
hitting two million uh
youtube subscribers this year let me
take a look at the social blade
trajectory future projections
let's take a look i would be
shocked if it's even remotely visible
feasible let's look at when it predicts
2 million
um wow it's actually not that so it's
not going to be this
calendar year but according to uh
socialblade
we're on track for 2 million subs within
14 months that's actually not bad
that's really not bad because we just
hit our first they say your first
millions your toughest
um that's interesting and that could be
accelerated to some to some extent maybe
yeah okay we'll keep an eye on that
let's go back and see what's happening
outside the courthouse racial disparity
for education employment and law
enforcement
justice is living in the world but we
have these conversations and don't try
to cover it up
and we came out here for george five
what's his name
say his name say
so a lot happening uh completely
peacefully
outside the courthouse right now and we
are standing by
for the verdict any minute any minute
supposed to be
supposed to be within the next seven
minutes okay
will the floyd death encourage patrons
to stop police if similar scenario
occurs
that's a big i don't know i don't think
so
i don't think so joe mama says
congratulations on 20 000 live stream
viewers oh is that right
oh look at that we've yeah 20k live on
youtube and 2k live on twitch
that's great i think we're live on
youtube on facebook as well
hold on let's take a look here
uh we are live on facebook i don't know
how many people are watching on facebook
but
facebook.com david pakman show let's
take a look
um oh another 2k okay so that's this is
a nice stream 24 000. i like that
yeah that's great welcome everybody if
you're just joining us
we are anticipating the a george floyd
derek chauvin
verdict imminently imminently
and eminently i don't know
will i make it on matt dillahunty's show
oh yeah hopefully hopefully
um it's just been crazy i haven't been
really doing any other shows
other than that one i did with uh
realtor kevin paffrath
fyi oh juvian hernandez is explaining to
me the ben hikaru drama
hikaru issued youtube strikes against
ben and others out of nowhere then
backtracked after negative publicity
check out ben's video i'm not gonna do
that now
because i know a lot of people in my
audience don't care about that but i'll
check it out later
um about to witness history with my
friend angel thanks for the platform
david yeah we we are all standing by
we're all standing by um
okay
let's see i'm gonna see if there is any
additional info this was announced
that it would be between 3 30 and 4
central time central time which is now
um not seeing
any changes so as far as i know we're
still expecting the verdict
any second and i've someone told me that
the jury is actually
in the room we are seeing that the
national guard
has been activated now i don't think
that that's breaking news i believe the
national guard was
activated days ago
um yeah
okay very good david i live in florida
but from the turks and caicos we'd love
to hear your thought on caribbean
vacation hope you visit at some point
yeah i was just in aruba um 10 days ago
and i don't know if technically aruba is
considered caribbean i know it's further
south
there's this little tip of venezuela
that's only like six
miles or six or seven miles from aruba
so i don't i don't know if aruba is even
considered
caribbean but um
i'm interested in getting to know more
of the caribbean for sure
and increasingly i'm doing more and more
banking there
that's a joke that's a joke i'm doing my
banking in
switzerland of course what is my chess
rating
depending on the time control and
website a thousand to 1250
something like that do discord server
boosters do something on your discord
server i believe they give us more
features
more features i did not see stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell
ii in aruba he arrived a few days after
i left
hello from australia says matt watching
the stream while riding the train to
work all the best and hopefully justice
is
served we are standing by for it
we are standing by let me say a few
thank yous to some people that i missed
i want to say thanks to
soul thief as well as this is slamming
john boy
as well um that's three
putting us at 125. also
on my website i want to say thank you to
rod henderson who signed up
sean robbins is a new member jackie
hoxie
is a new member and bonzo k
are all new members people asking
why is it better to sign up on my
website listen it's all good but
every platform takes a bunch of money
they want
slices and slices and slices on our
website we just pay two percent to swipe
credit and debit cards
that would be the reason to do it there
but we i don't
you know every any whatever you want to
do
this feels like the oj verdict all over
again to some degree it does
to some degree it does um
we have multiple video streams from
outside the courthouse
let's listen in a little bit this is
status quo not a trumpist channel
take a listen if we don't get it
if we don't get it if we don't
get it now cause blood loss matters
okay so we are standing by in the
courtroom
any minute now we are now just two
minutes from the end of the window that
was promised here
benjamin says is david a gamer not
really not really
david aruba is officially in the dutch
west indies group of islands does that
mean not in the caribbean
mile away from the colorado capital i'm
scared denver pd loves nothing more than
abusing people
second to doing absolutely nothing
nowhere i'll be
what would it take for fox to cut ties
with some of the more radical
propagandistic fear-mongering
fear-mongers they give a platform to
that it becomes not profitable period
i think that's it gesh makes has looked
it up aruba is indeed
in the mid-south caribbean okay
super effed up that black and brown
people are essentially paying police
through taxes to ice us
and our kids more complicated than that
but a horrible situation right now
involving police in the united states
and you know i think i want to be
careful that i
uh always sort of fully
explain my positions on these issues
which i've done
on a variety of youtube clips oh hold on
you mention jimmy from philly you
mentioned me moments after i left
you my first voicemail on your new line
okay let's see
and jimmy also says he's banned on
youtube jimmy
i never banned you excuse me i never
banned you on youtube
if you want to be unbanned i need you to
send me a link to your youtube profile
that's the only way
okay um
let's see jimmy from philly
hmm i'm not finding it
uh jimmy from philly oh wait is this it
give me some philly oh here it is hold
on a second i see what's going on
so jimmy's back let's listen real quick
david jimmy from philly what
so i'd love to join again but since she
got me
a shadow band no not this
i'm not gonna do it so if you lift the
band i'll join again but
you know you're probably not gonna do
that though i don't know
but uh i have a story where a black cop
set me up
claimed that uh a a black cop on seattle
street in philadelphia which is like uh
i don't know castrate is kind of like my
guess is i'll have to cut this because
it will get
inappropriate how could you describe
south street south street
is it has a bunch of bars it has a bunch
of
different like eclectic stores a
collection
it's like a party place and
i walked by a few cops they were
ticketing like a 90 some year old black
woman and it was like five cops around
the car
all right i'm done let's go to the next
one
hey david are you oops that's not even
jimmy from philly that's someone else
from the same area code sorry hold on
jimmy from philly white david i'm
watching your live stream now on the
show
just so you know okay there's another
jimmy from philly message
and then here's another one
david give me some film by the way
what's that weird beeping at the
beginning of every voicemail
it's only from him so i just joined
at the soyboy level tower 99 that sounds
appropriate
wow you know i here's a real question
should i be flattered or depressed
that jimmy from philly has often on been
a financial supporter of the show
despite the fact that we have such
political differences and his political
views are disgusting like is it
flattering or depressing i genuinely
don't know
it's both some people say okay that's
interesting
it's just funny it's neither
um and we've got more more anti-semitic
band hammers being dropped
it's both people seem to be saying okay
it's morph
it's depressing okay flattering
yeah i don't know i don't know
david what are your thoughts on biden's
infrastructure plan will it pass i don't
think it will pass
in its initial form i think it will pass
in some other form
also as someone from philly jimmy is an
asshat and doesn't represent my city
josiah says my fiancee ryan and i watch
you all the time thanks for your
reporting you are a joy to watch and
listen to also please stay safe
absolutely stay safe yeah i'm told that
we're getting very close
very very close to the verdict why do
you think people struggle to disavow
violence perpetrated by those on their
side
politically i don't know i've never
struggled with that so you'd have to
talk to someone who does
corey says tell joe dykstra to get back
to work yeah get back to work joe
um helen asks have i got
time to pop to the lou before the
verdict that sounds like a british
phraseology and that was a super chat
delivered in british pounds
i don't know helen at this point i don't
know
rise again says jimmy when we say all
cops are bastards that includes black
cops
wow okay that's i'm not a part of that
movement myself
but uh i guess that's for something to
for people who are part of it to talk
about
we continue to see live video from
status quo from outside the courthouse
in minneapolis and in minnesota
is it minneapolis i guess it is
and we are continuing to stand by for
the jury verdict in the derek chauvin
trial
i see hand sanitizer and a person
moving in the reflection in the lower
left so
maybe that means that we are soon going
to be getting this
verdict and that is now here we go
ladies and gentlemen verdict
in the george floyd killing
stand back and stand by
all right for the jury jury is now
entering
we don't want to miss a second of this
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict
gonna make uh notes about each charge
remember the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
here we go state of minnesota county of
hennepin district court
fourth judicial district state of
minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr2012646
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
guilty agreed to this 20th day of april
20. wow
1 44 p.m signs you're four person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter has to
count
two third-degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
wow agreed to this twentieth day of
april twenty whoa
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter has to count
three second-degree manslaughter
culpable negligence creating an
unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april
22 wow 25 p.m
jury four person zero one nine members
of the jury i'm now going to ask you
individually if these are
guilty on all counts please respond yes
or no
juror number two are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
oh my goodness are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
jury number 19 are these your true and
correct verdicts yes
juror number 27 are these your true and
correct verdicts
yes juror number 44
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 52
are these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 55 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 79 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 85 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 89 is this your are
these your true and correct verdicts
yes juror number 91 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes juror number 92 are these your true
and correct verdicts
yes are these your verdicts will say one
so say you all
yes yes members of the jury i find that
the verdict says read reflect the will
of the jury and will be filed
accordingly
wow i have to thank you on behalf of the
people of the state of minnesota guilty
on all counts but heavy duty jury
service what i'm going to ask you to do
now is
to follow the deputy back into your
usual room and i will join you in a few
minutes to answer questions
and to advise you further so wow rise
for the jury
i guess the lawyer didn't really do too
well with the cookie thing
i am shocked at guilty on all counts wow
now sentencing is a separate question
remember of course
right be seated this could signal a
change
with the guilty verdicts returned we're
going to have
blakely you may file a
written argument as to blakely factors
within one week
the court will issue findings on the
blakely factors the factual findings
one week after that we'll order psi
immediately
returnable in four weeks and we will
also have a briefing on after you get
the psi six weeks
from now and then eight weeks from now
we will have
sentencing wow two more months exact
dates uh
in a scheduling order is there a motion
on behalf of the state to have the court
uh revoke the defendant's bail and
remain him into custody
uh pending sentencing bail is revoked
bond is discharged and the defendant is
remanded to the custody wow
anything further things are getting very
real thank you
unbelievable wow and the handcuffs going
on derek shovin after
three guilty verdicts and
uh being led away by
court officers and court has now
adjourned
this is a do not pass go
do not collect 200 go straight to jail
situation
wow
wow um presumably
let's see now what's going on outside
do we know if the crowd knows the
verdict is the question
[Applause]
they do know okay don't you forget it
because they're gonna get on tv and say
the system works
and they'll be lying the system's gonna
work
we were homework we were this is our
victory
[Music]
i i did not expect guilty on all charges
i did not expect guilty on all charges
um but that that is that is something
um and uh that that is those are the
results
uh unbelievable unbelievable
and um i don't i mean i
i didn't even look into what sort of um
sentence there could be because i
assumed it would be weeks it's going to
be two months actually until
sentencing um but absolutely
um definitive unanimous guilty verdict
on
all three counts against derek chovin
and what i was starting to say before
was
this this may signal a change this may
be a message
that it's not going to be as simple
for use of force by police to lead to
acquittals or deals
in the future it could be a wake-up call
and
and and the best case scenario would be
this is an opportunity to really make
the reforms to policing
that people like me have been outlining
for for a very long time
uh it should be a wake-up call
incredible i am
i am surprised that guilty on all three
counts let's open the phone lines as i
promised i would when i promise to open
the phone lines i will do it
uh you can talk to me right now at
davidpakman.com discord in the waiting
lobby
that is how we take the terminology
this went over to cnn en espanol
um okay
but we're now away from that okay let's
hear from a few people
in the waiting lobby via discord before
i do that
uh whoa everything going wrong here i
want to say thank you just
i don't want to miss anybody danny chong
just got a website membership
david newman just signed up on my
website they are new members number 130
and 131
also chuck makes it as well as pink
bunny jmc
freedom jesus have signed up trithun
sobi i think that's it as far as twitch
goes
thanks very much um okay
let's listen to a few people here let's
go
directly to brian from arizona you were
on the air
let's go directly to brian
hey can you hear me yes i can oh hey uh
wow first person well i just watched the
well that's the verdict and really happy
with it um
i have some questions related to other
policy things though if you don't mind
we're really doing chauvin stuff right
now give me one other question let's not
do a list but maybe give me one other
okay um well i guess one thing uh
i guess if we want to stay a little one
thing i was wondering about is um you
just
like we're closing up that like job
search for your own one of your guys's
editors
yes and you required them to have a
college degree
yes and i was just wondering like you
know
why because there's a lot of people
doing that with like college like
requiring college degrees even though
the position doesn't necessarily um so
what what made you do that
it's really a filter because even with
that we got 350 applications and when
people wrote in and made the case that
they should be allowed to apply anyway i
allowed them when they said
you know i if they otherwise were good
fits um but otherwise you know we could
have 700 applications it was already
untenable
oh interesting okay cool cool um the
quick policy thing i had
and maybe you can address this later in
your show in a segment but i
really want like i've you know i've just
always been worried about
china lately and especially with all
their human rights stuff
and i wondered like what kind of uh
things you think the biden
administration should do
obviously we don't want to go to war or
anything but like what kind of
more uh strongman tactic or not
strongman but
like strong actions could the bind
administration take to like prevent
china from
doing all these human rights abuses if
if i were biden
if i were biden before doing more to
china
i would first undo the disastrous trade
war trump
escalated and that's going to take some
time and whether you can do that
and at the same time punish china for
human rights abuses i don't know but my
priority would be first let's fix
ideally in the first six months let's
try to find an off-ramp to trump's trade
policy with china
which has been disastrous for american
business
okay interesting yeah well cool all
right my friend
thank you very much yeah let's uh let's
see what else is on people's minds
let's go to julie from burlingame
california you're on the air
julie from burlingame california you're
on the air can you hear me david yes i
can
great thank you i am very relieved
with this verdict i'm surprised but but
pleasantly
and that this needs to be
an example um set you know for our
future because we
we need accountability and it's at the
point where
things things i know there's probably
going to be trouble you know regardless
of what the outcome or what the
you know the verdict was so far it's
looking like everybody's remaining calm
i mean i hope that that's not the case
i i agree i think that's great and i i
also
um i have a guest recommendation for you
i don't know how you
how you you book people um are you
familiar you're probably familiar with
the stanford prison
experiment of 1970 indeed um
i feel like that would feel zombardo
he's been on we've had him on before oh
you have yeah check out my youtube
channel it's in the archive yeah
oh my gosh okay okay i should have
checked first
well thank you very much for your your
coverage and i'm i'm uh
glad to be subscribed thank you i really
appreciate it
okay take care uh there is julie from
burlingame
let's go next to corey from jacksonville
florida
hey david can you hear me yes i can
hey um i i mean i'm really happy with
the outcome of the trial
um i was like you i was kind of
skeptical especially on the
third degree murder charge yeah
but uh but when i looked up earlier
today trying to find information
i saw that people were taking actual
bets on the trial and i was wondering
what your
opinion on that is i mean people can bet
on what i don't care
people can bet on whatever they want i
mean if if somebody will take your
action
i i don't have any moral problem with it
really i guess i mean it's just a market
fair enough i wouldn't be i mean i don't
bet on anything but there there are you
can bet on whatever at this point you
can bet on anything
it's not particularly classy i guess but
yeah
i guess the the fact that i
i feel weird that they were betting on
the murder of someone
right well they were betting on they
were betting on a legal outcome i guess
but
you know i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do
it yeah
um but hey anyways thanks for taking my
calls i'm a first time caller
um love your show thank you appreciate
it
really strong calls today actually um
let's go next to oh i don't know why do
why don't we go to david from florida
david are you calling from florida or
florida
hey david can you hear me yes i can
yeah i do it's florida oh okay sorry i
had it wrong thank you
no it's floored uh because you know um
you have all the open news down here you
never know
special spring break hey david uh thanks
for taking my call
my uh initial reactions are i think as
you say did this may be a change
and what i mean by that is you know
we're such a
national society now with the 24 hour
news and connected with social media
that
you know what happens here is going to
reverberate throughout the country but
also
you know you know the western world
right right and
and so i think that i think you know a
lot of things that people
may be turn internalizing this more now
about your vote does matter right
your vote does matter for president as
much as it matters for your local
office and you know this jury was buying
of the peers of the community
but i still think there's a greater
thing going on here too in terms of like
who's in office and
and who we elect i think there is i mean
it doesn't you know the
it doesn't necessarily directly relate
to
this verdict but i think the point is
that outcomes are directly rel outputs
are directly
uh caused by inputs and um i think
that's an important point for us to
remember
the agreement thank you so much all
right my pleasure david from florida
uh let's see who else we want to talk to
let's go to gabriella
from italy gabriella you were on the air
hi hello can you hear me yes i can
hi uh well i'm glad that i watched this
historic moment with your live stream i
actually had a
pressing question on uh vaccine
passports sure
um so you've been talking about on your
show how it's completely normal for a
private company to
require certain vaccines and things like
that which i completely agree with
however i am against vaccine passports
for the fact that
and i want to hear your opinion on this
that
the coven 19 vaccine under the wto is
only patented by certain countries
whereas vaccines like for measles for
example
are generic patents meaning that poorer
countries can reproduce these vaccines
whereas the coven 19 vaccine hasn't yet
been
patented as a generic drug true poor
countries are unable to
reproduce it meaning that they would not
be able to travel with these
private airlines due to the lack of
access to the patent so
when you say you're you're against a
vaccine passport when you say
you mean by who you're saying a travel
requirement by a country for tourists or
an airline for passengers or what
exactly are you saying
i would say that a vaccine passport for
international travel such as
i know that israel and the eu have been
trying to implement like the eu
specifically has said we want tourists
to have a vaccine
okay but again so you're saying that at
the country level or at the airline
level
um more specifically at the country
level but also for the airlines i mean
if it's an international flight
it would make it difficult for people
from poorer countries to
travel internationally if private
airliners are saying that
i i agree with you that that's certainly
a concern um
i think that it just has to be figured
out where maybe
there is an exact i mean listen right
now nobody's allowed to travel so i
think the argument that
once vac when you go from nobody you
know if you have an example of a country
where no one's allowed to go and then
you go to some people are allowed to go
saying you shouldn't allow some people
to go with a vaccine because you should
just make it no one
until everyone's vaccinated i think that
that's probably dubious
i'm open to the idea that for example
whatever country france might say if
you're coming from a country that is
already 50
vaccinated then you have to have a
vaccine
whereas countries that don't yet have
access you can take a negative test on
both sides or something like that you
know i'm open to figuring that out in
some way
yeah i just believe that there needs to
be more discussion on the fact that
poorer countries don't have access to
this patent which is a problem in and of
itself that is not yet patented as a
generic drug
sure i agree with you i'm with you there
thank you so much for the call
all right gabriella from italy let's go
next to billy from new york
billy from new york you're at the on the
air
billy from new york you're on air can
you hear me
yes
sorry i was expecting it honestly uh
what do you think the likelihood of a
mistrial i think it was called
no mistri mistrial's gone so the they
they asked for a mistrial already we now
have a verdict
we have a verdict so the maxine water
stuff
could be used for an appeal in theory
but uh we we do not have a mistrial we
have a verdict
okay and do you think there's any chance
that this may have been
possible uh like sometimes uh
people are saying uh intimidation for
the jury
yeah well i think that's the argument
that uh would be made on an appeal and i
don't i think that there's a chance that
it could be successful i'm actually
worried about that sentencing is in
eight weeks for people asking about that
that's all i was wondering about all
right thanks very much uh great to hear
from you
let's talk to a couple of other people
why don't we go
to uh sammy from indiana sammy from
indiana you're on the air
by the way people messaging me and
calling me on discord
guys i the only way is you get in the
waiting lobby
do not send me any messages do not try
to call me on discord okay sorry sammy
go ahead
hey can you hear me yes i can yeah my
sort of
question for you is um so of course i
agree with
you know everything that happened
transpired yeah uh but
you know i think it's fair to say that
had not all three counts
even if he he were charged with one of
the three counts
he there might have been severe violence
uh
charged or convicted hold on charged or
convicted which one are you referring to
uh just charged i think like even today
if
not all three charges were passed just
one of them passed maybe even none of
them
you're talking about conviction not
charges right oh conviction
yeah sorry you're saying if with the
three charges if he had only been
convicted on one
you believe there would have been
violence yes yes
um do you think that's that's
necessarily a bad thing
um because i do think you know public
pressure was sort of instrumental
um in the outcome uh but you know
at the same time you know there's this
idea of respecting our institutions and
all that
so i wanted your perspective on that i'm
against violence
and um you know it's a hypothetical what
would have happened with only one
conviction
that we had three convictions and for
now things seem very peaceful
i have to ask sammy are you wrapping
sandwiches in deli paper
uh no i am speaking through my
headphones you are okay
all right very good yeah okay good well
listen let's uh let's
hope for continued a peaceful
demonstration
yeah i agree all right thank you very
much for the call appreciate that
we're hearing from some very interesting
people today i like it
let's go next to tyler from
illinois tyler you're on the air hi
um can you hear me i can awesome
um i'm obviously really happy with
everything with that with the trial on
anything but uh
i'm gonna kind of take a really quick
pivot on something that i saw on the
news
sure so uh i've been always really
interested
in you know the middle east you know the
kurdish question isis and all that kind
of stuff
um and so i think again talking about
the hypocrisy of the conservatives is
that lindsey graham
went on and talked and blamed president
biden for
the increase of isis in the middle
eastern
area which i think is really funny
because the increase of
an isis in the middle east is a direct
consequence of
donald trump removing a lot of our
troops
from like from aiding the kurds um
and i just think it's a really you know
i just again i think it's
the hypocrisy of the conservatives
because before i mean everyone
i believe everyone was kind of hesitant
when trump talked about removing troops
from the kurds
but the the the conservative party
instead of saying well
maybe we should reinstate you know
troops helping in the middle east
they turn to biden with you know in his
first 100 days and blame the rise of
isis
on him instead of their predecessor yeah
it's it's not
uh you're completely right it's
hypocrisy and it's delusional but it's
not even just on this issue that they're
doing it they're doing it on everything
from gas prices to um
you know coveted deaths i mean it's it's
it's nonsense hypocrisy and
unfortunately a lot of them fall for it
i know and it's just funny because i
remember when they said oh you know
donald trump has created peace in the
middle east and i'm like
i i think like these these conservatives
must be delusional because
between countries that already weren't
in conflict
exactly and i'm like you you're you know
he's making these like you know
faux pas peace deal saying oh look at me
i did this when you know he's
you know first destroying our
relationship
uh with palestine which is you know a
whole topic in and of itself
but then him saying well we're just
going to pull over truth from the kurds
and then took no accountability for it
and the conservatives are like well
since we
you know since we want to blame biden
for you know something that obviously
wasn't his fault we'll just use
you know the kurds again like they
always like to you know
push the blame towards yeah now on the
other hand joe biden
became president and within like a few
weeks we we landed a rover on mars so i
think that's also really a big thing for
biden too
yeah it is but like i just think it's
funny how the conservatives are
saying oh well you know trump is the
trump
is you know most normal people would see
what's going on in the middle east and
saying well trump pulling the troops
out from you know helping you know
kurdish allies yeah is what caused
you know isis to begin taking you know
holes in afghanistan everything but
right
no you know every time i'm like oh maybe
they're gonna
get better but you know they always
prove me wrong every time anybody should
stop giving them sympathy
yep uh we have to have very low
expectations for them
thank you for the call i appreciate it
thank you yeah and just to be clear i
was kidding like i know that
the the the mars thing it was launched
nine months ago so i like i
it's a joke i know trump was president
um
at that point in time okay that's going
to do it for
calls today i do appreciate everybody
that i was
able to speak to and to some degree i
even appreciate the people i was not
able
to speak to we have a guilty verdict
on all three counts for derek chauvin
in the killing of george floyd and
chauvin has been
taken into custody he was immediately
handcuffed
immediately handcuffed and um
it's it's getting uh it's it's going to
get very real at sentencing
eight weeks from now all right everybody
thank you for joining me
i am back in the studio out of the
bunker
and we will have plenty of streams and
then next wednesday joe biden's doing
his big
joint address between before the house
and senate that's next wednesday
and we will have a big nighttime stream
for that and maybe even take phone calls
who knows
all right everybody see you soon
you